hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
for my forum readers who wrote in about
passion so she wrote in asking I don't
know what my passion is how do I find it
great question and definitely something
that you want to check out before use
launch of business a lot of
entrepreneurs start a company just
trying to make money without doing
something a really passion about and
they rarely end up being successful
you'll find that the ones who are the
most successful are the ones who really
love their business are truly passionate
what they're doing and they're more
likely to be a lot more successful so
it's definitely worth investigating
spending some time doing some
soul-searching to figure out what your
passion is before you go launch your
business because in the long term you
have a much greater chance of success so
in terms of how do you find your
passions a couple ways to do it
the first thing I would look at is what
are you already doing you know outside
of whatever job you have or whatever
you're doing to make money right now
what are you doing that you find really
enjoyable and you're able to help people
add a lot of value to their lives
chances are as well as some things that
you're doing maybe is based around a
hobby that you have or some skill that
you have that you're helping people
maybe it's for free just friends and
family but you find that that they
really appreciate what you're doing and
you're adding a lot of value to a lot
their lives and there is there a way
that you can turn that into a potential
business sometimes you think that we're
good at we're not necessarily super
passionate about so we don't want to
build into anything but often some of
the things we go to and work hard up
just outside on our own if it's a hobby
or a skill there's ways to turn that
into our own business and you'll
probably be excited to go and do that
every morning so it's definitely looking
at what you're doing to help people
because that's what a business is all
about the more you can help people the
more successful you're gonna be the more
money you're gonna make so what are you
doing right now that's already helping
people you're getting really good
feedback even if you're not getting paid
there may be a way to turn it into a
business so that's my first way to look
at it the second way to look at it is
what are some frustrations that you feel
in your own life what are things that
you're struggling with
and you really wish there was a solution
for maybe you can go out and try to find
a solution for it and and help yourself
and also help other people in that
process so is there anything in your own
life your day-to-day existence that you
find really really frustrating you wish
there was a solution out there maybe
there's a way you can create that kind
of solution that would help you and also
help other people who are like you so
quick example for my background when I
sold my first software company I was in
a fortunate position of not having to go
do anything for a while
but I wanted to do something right you
don't want to just sit around and do
nothing all day I'm not the kind of guy
who wants to just sit on the beach all
day long
so the next thing it was hooked up with
a venture capital company and we started
raising expansion capital for companies
and that was something that was
interesting for me and I could also add
a lot of value to my friends because
they were asking how do I raise capital
and how do we go through this process I
want to get my company up and sold and
having gone through the process myself I
then was able to help some of my
entrepreneurial friends who were in my
same city do some of the same things
themselves
so that was where I was able to take
something that it was kind of already
doing on the side and be able to turn
that into more of a business and then
the second thing I did was I launched my
website so I launched seven chemical
calm and at first there wasn't a
business model behind it it was just
something I did because I really liked
doing it I found with my software
business I got started when I was 19 so
pretty young didn't really know anything
about sales or software or running the
business before and I was kind of scared
at the beginning right 19 year old kid
and what I found was you know I was a
little girl wild the next thought I'm
not the first guy to go and try to sell
software and I started researching
companies like Microsoft McAfee Intuit a
couple others and looked at how did they
get started
how did they go from nothing to the
first million and how can I do something
similar and I use those strategies to
help me grow my business and I thought
that could be a really cool way to also
help other entrepreneurs so I launched
comical calm sharing a lot of the famous
entrepreneur profiles and stories that I
found inspired me so the first part of
what I did was a venture capital
business and that was just something I
was doing to help other entrepreneurs
and I found that I was able to you know
make some money in the process as well
by helping them grow their business and
the second part is I launched a
MacArthur comm based on a pain that I
saw for me personally a frustration that
here was this young guy starting the
business had no idea what I was doing
and then realizing that if I just copied
the strategies is why they're famous
entrepreneurs I could achieve some
success on my own as well and out of
that frustration I was able to help
other entrepreneurs and we've built up
now the largest collection of famous
entrepreneur profiles anywhere online so
that was kind of the beginnings of Evan
Carmichael calm and I still love what I
do every day I love helping
entrepreneurs and that's the backbone of
my business I love helping out my
prayers and help them grow their
business and start a new business as
well so that was the discovery I went
through after selling my first offer
company and was able to get to this
point and very grateful for it and
hopefully by going through that same
journey of self-discovery you will find
something you really love and can be
really successful at as well but you
know make sure you don't start anything
until you're you're really passionate
about it don't just do something because
you think you have to do something and
you're just trying to make a buck try to
do something where you feel you're
really excited about it and you think
you can add a ton of value to your
customers and people we're going to
eventually you know pay you for your
services or for your product hope for
the help if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below I you
know really instead motivates me to want
to make more of these videos for you
guys and if you have a question about
this video or you have a question of
your own about your own company feel
free to leave it in the comments below I
always read those and try to respond to
as many as I can so thank you and we'll
see you on the next episode
you